sébastien est venue avec ses enfants à
la patinoire après avoir chaussé les
patins direction la glace pas trop de
soucis pour ce papa qui a fait du roller
étant jeune pour ces deux garçons c'est
un peu plus difficile pour occuper un
petit peu les enfants donc étant juste à
côté
c'est pratique et puis c'est pas très
cher s'expliquer parce que j'arrivais
pas de faire des chutes la cité un tout
petit peu compliqué mais il parfois il
ya 28 ans s'est passé j'ai allégé avait
comme ça sans les mains en vacances chez
la cousine de sa mère anna a déjà fait
du patinage elle enflamme la glace avec
ses patins sous les yeux de sa famille
elle nous livre son secret il faut
d'abord essayer d'avancer un pied et
après le deuxième et après ainsi de
suite et après eux et après il faut un
moment rabat les pieds avancer tout
droit et ça normalement ça glisse 6 1 a
pris de l'élan
j'ai pas sur la patinoire parce qu'elle
est un peu petit et qu'on s'est dit
qu'on allait laisser la place aux
enfants mais on prend les photos voilà
tu souvenir si on retrouve une majorité
de familles valentin hommes josselin et
jean lucas sont venus s'éclater entre
amis avec des jeux un peu particulier
bon ce qui est à faire des courses
voilà où on doit se pousser
paris le premier à la l'autre côté de la
patinoire
la patinoire sera ouverte jusqu'au 24
décembre de 14h à 20h toute la semaine
avec une nocturne prévue vendredi 23
jusqu'à 22 heures et de 13 heures à 18
heures le dernier jour